it's a reasonably Raikou founder of no
film school calm announced that he's
making manchild the short film before he
makes manchild a feature and there's
various reasons all of which are very
valid he says the reason to make this
short is not only to help financing or
raise financing but to you know get word
out about the project to gain
credibility in the basketball world
excuse me to hone his chops in terms of
shooting pace and things like that do
you find that filmmakers you often
interact with have this same business
mindset when it comes to making short
films a lot of times a pretty good
amount of the fellows we yeah good
hermanos we get a festival or are made
with the with the feature film you know
intentions in mind I don't know they
have the same exact plan where it sounds
like he's a very specific plan where he
has this plan that get placed he knows
what he wants to do with his film make
the film test things out and then you
know charting investors and test out he
has a certain plan in place that's
probably more specific and write better
and it's smart to do more so than some
of the films and filmmakers we have the
fest because a lot of times if it's a
student filmmaker they're first-time
film they want to make a new feature
they don't even know the steps of how to
do that but they want to make this
they're kind of not just calling card
but more of uh you know a showcase of
what the story could be you know whether
it is that you know first two minutes
the film or you know if it's almost like
the first act or just more this is the
kind of story they want to tell this is
what the short is but made the feature
version will just be an extension of
that whether you know like that kind of
thing so you get a lot a lot of that
where the films that we were screening
I don't know percentage-wise but me
because there are a lot that are also is
just short films or remains pacifically
to be assured not to be a feature to
tell us your story certain way and be a
short film and I stand alone but there
are a lot of films that intention is
okay I could turn this in a feature
eventually you know or category once
those are horror shorts the great they
essentially want to make those into
features and just finish the script and
just go ahead and shoot a feature film
of the film that they did
as I saved up again in the horror
category for instance you get a lot out
with that category and some people
already have that in place you know they
had a script ready and then shining go
out there and meet people at the
festival - you know hustle and make that
happen and so folks just that's their
intention but they haven't gotten the
point where they are ready to even shoot
a feature but you do see a lot of that
plan is that these films and going back
to stuffing something like this the
festival a lot of films we have are the
this is the first film and a journey for
people you know that are going on the
China make feature films and work in
this business and make more movies this
is not the end-all be-all this is the
beginning so this is very early in the
process of a person's career and you
know what that majority of these films
are you know the filmmakers have feature
film aspirations for these these stories
are there near and dear to them but it's
not all of them obviously it's a certain
percentage of them that are there that
but do you only see a certain amount of
filming as you talk to they have a real
plan in place already with the short to
feature like we've seen that a few times
like last year we did have a film that
we screen the feature the year before we
screen the short and but at the same
time they were shooting the short
already having the feature film in mind
and the budget in place they're actually
just getting that they want to get that
short out there a little bit and they
were already had the plans they already
had financing for the feature they just
wanted to get the short out there a
little bit to kind of just get the word
out and also just kind of get the buzzin
and word out really so that that's a
similar scenario but they also again
they had financing there already were
going to make feature film I just want
to get the short after they say they
shot a scene of the film being a short
got out there submitted festivals while
they're actually making a feature film
so you know of the same core story so
that was a good example there but they
literally were shooting the film already
and they had a feature like their
financing in the you know that was
pre-production in place they're already
rate they were going so you know but you
see some of that you definitely see some
of that and then there's it I think it's
a good idea you know I think it's it so
it so it's one way it's something you
can show them better to show people like
this is what we have this is what I can
do outside of just you know pitching
them with nothing you have something and
if you do have to start attached to the
star
talent that can help financing in there
in the film even better for that reason
you know if they're going to see if they
can see that the persons in the film and
they can see the work and see what it is
and persons attached and literally in
the short you know that you know we've
seen that before then our fest and you
know and we've seen that example and I
think that's definitely something that
works
you